This video is sponsored by Brilliant.
The first 200 to use the link in the description
get 20% off their annual premium subscription.
Imagine the perfect cattle-grazing pasture.
Blue skies, green grass, shared by everyone.
Of course, it can still only support so many
cows.
If the farmers were smart, they’d figure
out how many, and divide that among them.
But that’s a big “if”.
Because the incentives are all wrong.
More likely everyone would act in their own
best interest, bringing more and more cows
until they destroyed the land and no-one could
use it.
This is The Tragedy of the Commons.
When resources are shared but limited, people
will act selfishly and ruin it for everyone.
It happens in public parks, traffic, and fishing.
But sometimes, the opposite happens, and that’s
the story of patents.
Instead of land, it’s ideas.
And the problem is not that everything is
shared, it’s that nothing is.
Big companies claim everything they lay their
eyes on,
They patent the process of making decisions,
rounding rectangles, even, if you can believe
it, filing patents.
You name it, someone technically owns it.
Maybe you don’t plan on using it, but at
least you can stop your competitors.
And what’s a few thousand dollars in filing
fees to a company making 265 billion a year?
But all this ownership leaves little room
for innovation.
Just imagine how hard it would be to design
a new smartphone today without violating anyone’s
patents.
Good.
Luck.
Even if you could somehow figure out which
ones you needed to license, which is already
a stretch, it would simply be far too expensive.
We think of invention as a sudden flash of
inspiration, but usually big ideas are just
one improvement on the last, or some new combination.
Smartphones, for example, are a bunch of different
ideas put together.
And I mean a bunch.
Google’s chief legal officer says they might
be susceptible to as many as a quarter million
patent claims.
That’s a mess.
All of this means that patents can be not
just ineffective, but actually counterproductive.
So, what’s the solution?
How can we encourage innovation in a way that,
ya know, actually works?
There are two ways to look at patents.
First, as a right.
Creating things takes time and effort.
If you paint a picture, or write a story,
it belongs to you, so why should inventions
be any different?
Physically or otherwise, No-one wants to be
stolen from.
This is why we use the term “Intellectual
Property”, it’s no different than a house
or a car.
which I’d argue is kind of true - a patent
can be bought, sold, licensed, or abandoned.
But if ideas are simply property, the inventor
of a life-saving drug could just decide not
to share it.
And if companies deserve monopolies over their
creations, we’re stuck with the system we
have.
Sure, in theory, we could adjust it, Shorten
the length of patents from 20 to 10, or 5,
or even 2 years, Ban Patent Trolls, Or be
more selective about which patents are approved.
All of these would be a huge help.
But they wouldn’t solve the fundamental
problem.
To do that, we need to view them not as a
right but a trade.
You and I promise to give companies a temporary
monopoly, and they invest the time and money
to make the products we want.
But we’re being ripped off.
We’re often giving a monopoly when a company
would’ve made their product anyway.
In other words, we’re trading a lot for
really nothing in return.
Would Apple stop making iPhones if they couldn’t
file patents?
They might make less money, but they’d almost
certainly still be profitable.
Even with copycats, they could stand out with
things like better engineering talent and
marketing.
How do we know this?
Because it’s already true.
Xiaomi makes every attempt to replicate products
like the iPhone, but I’d say Apple is still
doing okay.
Or, look at Lego, whose patents expired in
twenty eleven, but still makes billions of
dollars.
If anything losing them made the company more
innovative by giving it better competition.
Of course, this isn’t always true.
A pharmaceutical company, for example, may
truly need patents to protect its investment.
But the goal is to give them just enough incentive,
and not a dollar more.
And that exact amount varies by industry.
Which brings us to the wonderful world of
software patents.
From the outside, you may not think it's any
different.
An invention is an invention, whether it’s
made of gears or ones and zeros.
But you’d be wrong.
With software, the problems are ten times
worse.
They account for about 75% of all troll lawsuits,
and are twice as likely to be litigated.
Here’s the difference.
A physical invention can easily be described
as its parts.
A ballpoint pen, for example, can be patented
as a tube, an ink reservoir, and a rotating
ball.
But a digital one, of course, is made of code.
And because there are many ways to program
the same function, it wouldn’t make sense
to patent specific lines of code.
Someone could just slightly change it.
And, besides, that's already protected by
copyright.
So, instead, software patents usually describe
less a process or method and more an idea
or function.
That’s the difference between patenting
toy bricks which stack using cylindrical grooves,
and the idea of connecting two objects.
The later sounds ridiculous, no-one should
own such a basic concept, but it happens all
the time in software.
The other difference is that, unlike, say,
pharmaceuticals, software development is dirt
cheap.
Because nothing is manufactured, there’s
no limit to its scale.
When Instagram was bought by Facebook for
a billion dollars, it employed only 13 people.
And WhatsApp had 55 when it was bought for
20 billion.
What matters is speed.
A brand new software startup can beat the
biggest companies on the planet if it moves
fast enough.
which means, by the time a patent is granted,
it may no longer be relevant.
Compare this with government, whose strength
is being slow and methodical, and you can
see why it doesn’t mix so well with tech.
So, if patents are really a trade, and different
industries require different incentives, it
only makes sense to negotiate individually.
Why should the inventor of a buy-now button
be granted just as long a monopoly as the
creator of a drug that took years and years
of research.
The solution is a prize system, where the
first inventor gets a check, not a monopoly.
This way, companies compete, lower prices,
and make their products more accessible.
Not in 20 years, when their patent expires,
but today.
Many new companies would finally have a fighting
chance.
And, as a nice cherry on top, patent trolls
would be eliminated overnight.
Of course, there are some challenges, We’d
need a system for determining what kind of
inventions require a prize.
And that money would have to come from somewhere.
Which probably means, your favorite, higher
taxes.
Again, it’s not perfect, but it need only
be 1% better than what we have.
And that’s already a pretty low bar.
So, if such a simple solution exists, why
aren't we using it?
For one, because the companies that benefit
most from patents are the ones with money
to lobby for them.
And because many people just don't know much
about economics.
There just isn’t much awareness.
But patents and the stock market are really
economic games.
And with today's sponsor, Brilliant, you can
learn the hidden, mathematical rules to better
understand them.
It teaches concepts like game theory, economic
statistics, and tons of other topics on science,
math, and computer science.
Unlike your professor, Brilliant understands
that people learn by doing, not just memorizing
over and over again.
So you'll solve riddles, play with graphs,
and answer challenges as you progress through
the lessons.
To get started or dive deeper into the world
of math, science, and technology, go to brilliant.org/Polymatter
and sign up today for free.
The first 200 people to use that link will
also get 20% off the annual Premium subscription.
Thanks to Brilliant for sponsoring this video,
and, as always, to you for listening.